Good morning, John, it's Friday, September 17th!
I don't look very good, I'm going to change the white balance.
That's better, there's a little more color in my skin.
The great thing about being a person who only exists in videos...
is that you don't have to go outside to get color,
you can just change the white balance.
Now I'm extra orange. And now I could go out clubbing on the Jersey Shore!
Excellent.
John, I have decided to follow your and Amy Krouse Rosenthal's lead
and do some positive pranking today.
I was thinking to myself 'What is the most common form of prank?'
The answer is, of course, the prank CALL.
"Hey, is your refrigerator running?"
"Well, you better go catch it."
But I am taking that idea and turning it positive
by prank calling people with encouraging and true facts about our world.
But unfortunately Montana is one of the twelve states in which you can not
record a phone call unless all parties have agreed to the recording.
So, you're just going to get me. You're just going to get my side of the conversation.
Okay, it's ringing...
Uh, an answering machine.
I guess I can use an answering machine.
Hi, this is Hank Green of the Vlogbrothers,
and I just wanted to let you know that teen smoking, teen pregnancy, and teen drug use
have all declined significantly since the late 1990s.
Its ringing..... hi!
This is Hank Green of the Vlogbrothers and I
just wanted to let you know
that cancer rates are decreasing
significantly
year-over-year. No, it's not just because
of lung cancer. That's a really good point though.
Lung cancer is decreasing, and that is
part of it, but it's also because of
increased screening
for pre-cancerous lesions and also the
HPV vaccine.
Ah, yeah, it's good news. I just wanted to
let you know cuz it's good news.
Yeah, okay. Bye.
That went really well!
I'm surprised by how well that went.
Okay, I'm going to start telling people facts and then hanging
up immediately because I feel like
that's more prank-like
than talking to them. Hi, this is Hank Green of the Vlogbrothers and I just wanted to
let you know the global poverty rates
have dropped
30 percent since 1990 and they're on
track
to drop another 10 percent before 2015.
She was talking and I just hung up on her.
Haha! Pranked! Hi, this is Hank Green of the Vlogbrothers and I just wanted to let
you know the divorce rates are actually
much lower that people generally assume.
Eighty percent of people who got married
in the nineteen eighties are still married.
*laughter* It's fun, it's exhilarating!
Hi, I just wanted to let you know that in
the nineteen seventies there were only
four hundred breeding pairs of bald
eagles left,
but since the passage of the
Endangered Species Act
that has gone up to over 10,000 breeding pairs
of bald eagles. Hi, this is Hank Green of the Vlogbrothers and I just wanted to let you know
that violent crime rates
have dropped every year since 1970 and they dropped
5 percent between, ah... 2008 and 2009 alone. So I have successfully
positively prank called
10 people, and that, I think, is a good
day's work.
I'm gonna put a transcript of my script that I
used for my positive pranks down in the doobly-doo,
so that you can make your own positive
prank calls because they are perfectly
legal to do,
though occasionally people seem somewhat
annoyed at me.
Thank you to people who follow me on
Twitter for suggesting most of these.
I didn't find these on my own, I asked
people to find me encouraging statistics
about the world
and people were very kind and sent some of these in and I genuinely hope that the
people who I positively pranked today
will think about the encouraging fact
that I told them about the world and they
will feel better
about the state of our planet
and our society because it's very easy to
get discouraged. But I really think that
that's only because we get told the bad news
and we never get told the good news and so I just wanted to tell some people
some good news today.
John, I will see you on Monday.